Let's suppose that AS200 originates a prefix and that the path that result from
the original BGP routing are shown in
green. Let's now suppose that AS100 seeks to
become a man in the middle. If the original prefix being advertised was P, AS
100 could also advertise the prefix P, but we want to make sure that AS
100 maintains a path back to AS 200. Now that path already exists,
it's right here. So what we want to do is make sure that neither AS 10
nor as 20 except this hijacked route. The way that we can do
that is through a technique called as-path poisoning.
So, if AS 100 advertises a route that includes
AS 10 and AS 20 Both of these AS's will drop the announcement because they will
think they've already heard the announcement and don't
want to form a loop. On the other hand,
the other AS's on the internet, in other words, every other AS that's not on the
path back from 100 to 200 will switch and now all of the traffic from other AS's
enroute to AS 200 will traverse the attacker AS100. Now
a trace route might look awfully funny taking this circuitous route, but
actually the attacker can hide its presence even if the sender is running a
trace route. Recall that a trace route simply consists of
ICMP time exceeded messages. That result when a particular packet
reaches a TTL of 0. Now typically each
router along a path will decrement the TTL at
each hop. But if the routers in the
attacker's network never decrement the TTL, then no time
exceeded messages would be generated by routers in
AS 100. Therefore the traceroute would never show AS
100 on the path at all. So now that
we've talked about the importance of origin authentication and
attacks against it, let's talk a little bit about session authentication.